MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Today, we're talking
about Data Fusion, new cloud
certifications, and Google
Cloud Next 2020.
I'm Mark Mirchandani,
and welcome to "This Week
in Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
Cloud Data Fusion is our
fully managed data integration
service that simplifies how
you authenticate, monitor,
and protect your data.
And we've just released new
beta features, such as support
for VPC service controls.
Check the blog for an overview
of the built-in features
working to keep your data safe.
Last September, we announced
improvements to the Cloud Build
GitHub app, making it
easier for developers
to trigger builds on
specific branches, pull
requests, or tags.
We're happy to announce that
those features are all now
generally available.
Go try them out.
For 2020, we've got two
new certification programs.
The Google Cloud
Certified Fellow
is an invitation-only
certification program
for technical leaders
designing enterprise solutions
with Anthos.
Through a series of
assessments and labs,
the program will identify
experts who can effectively
lead organizations through
frictionless hybrid multi-cloud
adoption.
And the Professional Cloud
DevOps Engineer Certification
enables cloud professionals
to demonstrate their expertise
in development operations
and service reliability
to employers.
Check them out if you're looking
to add more certifications
to add to your collection.
We just announced the dates
for Google Cloud Next 2020.
Join us in San Francisco
or online April 6
through April 8 for
some Google Cloud magic.
Registration is now open
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.